it calls to mind events that occurred
more than a century ago
which means the key to the present
dilemma may lie in the past
understanding patterns and historical
attacks can also help us to understand
patterns and current attacks so experts
are turning their attention back all the
way back
- the very first significant shark
attack spike in US history 1916 the
Jersey Shore when terror reign the 1916
shark attacks on the New Jersey Shore
for the greatest shark attack mystery of
all time and really the movie Jaws in
the book would not have been possible
without it though people at the time
believed sharks to be harmless five
beachgoers are bitten in just two weeks
or lose their lives causing panic up and
down the eastern seaboard for years
experts have studied these attacks and
struggled to explain what happened
but there is one parallel between the
very first fatal attack in 1916 and one
of the more recent attacks that might
prove to be more than a coincidence they
both happen at similar times of day in
1916 the first fatal victim was bitten
around 5:00 p.m. just like Ida Parker
who's about five o'clock in the
afternoon
and according to shark expert dr. Dan
Hueber this may not be mere chance
recent research has shown that sharks
can use the angle of the Sun in order to
give them a predatory advantage if a
shark is hunting when the Sun is high
overhead the water is brightly lit and
potential prey can easily see the Sharks
approach it's going to illuminate the
shark perhaps so much so that it's
really not worth their time to hunt
during the middle of the day but when
the Sun is lower in the sky like it is
around 5 p.m.
everything changes to explain Hueber
sets up a demonstration here we have a
small lure which represents the shark
next we have a GoPro camera which
represents the point of view of the prey
and last we have the light which
represents the Sun when the Sun is close
to the horizon sharks approach prey
using a very clever method they'll
position the Sun behind themselves so if
the prey were to look where the shark is
coming from
it's gonna be blinded by the Sun as you
can see from the footage the scene gets
completely washed out making it harder
to see the oncoming predator this may be
key to understanding the attacks because
doing part to this camouflage sharks
often hunt at two particular times of
day sharks will be more actively hunting
during dawn and dusk
as a result experts the world over
advise beachgoers to avoid the water
both early and late in the day when they
may run into a hunting shark
so we're beach goers in 1916 and today
simply swimming during these dangerous
times Huber examines the data and finds
that while most of the victims in both
spikes were bitten during the afternoon
none were bitten at dawn or dusk so the
idea that this would have caused the
attachment simply isn't supported
[Music]
you